“El aleteo de una mariposa puede causar
un tifón en algún lugar del mundo”
El 20 de abril de 2021, el presidente de Chad
fue asesinado en un enfrentamiento con una
guerrilla.
Una semana más tarde, 3 periodistas han sido
asesinados en Burkina Faso, 2 de ellos eran
españoles.
De repente, todos los medios están hablando
de la región del SAHEL: la zona más castigada
del mundo.
Se trata de la franja de tierra que separa
el desierto del Sahara de la gran sabana africana.
El Sahel es tan violento como Irak pero mucho
más pobre.
Ha sufrido colonialismo, desertificación
y ahora se está convirtiendo en el nuevo
foco del terrorismo islámico.
Y esta vez hablamos de terroristas que podrían
llegar a conquistar algunas de las minas de
uranio más importantes del mundo.
Es decir, que podrían conseguir uranio con
el que fabricar las llamadas “bombas sucias”.
Pese a todo esto, Estados Unidos está retirando
las pocas tropas que tenía en la zona.
Cada vez se ven más mercenarios rusos por
la región.
Y sólo hay una potencia con un interés claro
en esta región: FRANCIA.
Y diréis ¿Pero qué le importa a Francia
lo que ocurre en el Sahel?
¿Qué tiene que ver el efecto mariposa con
todo esto?
¿Y por qué deberíamos preocuparnos por
lo que ocurre en mitad de África?
En este vídeo te lo vamos a explicar.
Hoy en día es fácil denunciar los abusos
que cometió el Imperio español o el imperio
británico, pero, seamos honestos, si ha habido
una potencia colonial depredadora, ese es
sin duda el Imperio Francés.
Hasta los años 70, Francia había colonizado
casi un tercio de toda la población africana:
Argelia, Mali, Chad... todos estos son algunas
de las muchas ex colonias francesas.
Durante más de siglo y medio, Francia explotó
los recursos naturales de este continente
dejando a su paso sociedades rotas.
A su lado, los conquistadores españoles y
británicos habrían parecido los ositos amorosos.
Y ahora siguen haciendo lo mismo pero de otra
forma.
En la llamada FRANCAFRIQUE, Francia quita
y pone a los dictadores que más le conviene.
Y esto nos lleva de vuelta al Sahel.
Y diréis ¿Pero qué es el Sahel?
Se trata de la franja que separa el desierto
del Sahara de las grandes sabanas africanas.
Una zona donde es prácticamente imposible
cultivar nada, donde las seguías son frecuentes
y donde 8 de cada 10 habitantes vive con 1,90
dólares al día.
Os lo hemos dicho mil veces en VisualPolitik:
la pobreza está desapareciendo en el mundo.
Sin embargo, el Sahel es uno de los pocos
lugares donde persiste y no parece que haya
ninguna señal de mejora.
Más bien todo lo contrario.
Y no penséis que hablamos de una región
pequeña.
Fijaos en este mapa.
En el sahel viven más de 300 millones de
personas repartidas en varios países: Burkina
Faso, Mali, Níger, Chad... y otros tantos
más.
Para que os hagáis una idea de lo grande
que es esta región, la distancia de este
a oeste es la misma que la que hay desde Madrid
hasta Nueva York.
Pues bien, el sahel siempre ha sido pobre
pero ahora, a toda esta miseria se suma la
violencia.
Miles de personas mueren cada año a manos
de distintos grupos terroristas: tanto Al
Qaeda como el Estado Islámico tienen sus
franquicias por aquí.
Y su presencia es cada vez más importante.
Todo esto explica noticias como esta.
Francia desplegará más tropas para luchar
contra los extremistas en el Sahel
A día de hoy, Francia tiene más de 5.000
efectivos desplegados en el Sahel.
La ONU lleva ocho años con la operación
MINUSMA para estabilizar la situación en
Mali.
La Unión Europea tiene dos misiones de entrenamiento
y envía varios millones de euros en ayuda
humanitaria cada año.
Pero, hasta la fecha, nada de esto ha servido.
Mientras tanto, tanto Turquía como Rusia
están prestando cada vez más atención a
esta región.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Qué es exactamente
lo que está haciendo Francia en esta región?
¿De verdad es tan importante lo que está
ocurriendo en el Sahel?
Hoy, vamos a responder a estas preguntas,
pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia.
EL TRIÁNGULO DEL MAL
Si el Sahel fuera un país, en términos de
población sería el cuarto país más grande
del mundo.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, esta región
es de todo menos homogénea: hay muchísimas
desigualdades y diferencias si comparamos
la parte occidental y la oriental.
Así que, en el vídeo de hoy, nos vamos a
centrar en cinco países del Sahel central
y occidental.
Hablamos de Burkina Faso, Chad, Mali, Mauritania
y Níger.
Estos países tienen en común tres cosas:
los cinco forman desde 2014 una alianza que
se conoce como el G5 del Sahel.
Los cinco fueron colonias francesas y ahora
son dictaduras fallidas.
Es decir, dictaduras donde el dictador ni
siquiera tiene control sobre todo el territorio.
Ese espacio lo cubren tribus y grupos terroristas.
Pero si todo esto ya suena mal, hay una zona
dentro del Sahel que es aún peor.
La llamada “triple frontera” o, lo que
podríamos llamar, el “triángulo del mal”.
Atentos a este mapa.
Como podéis ver, hablamos de esta triple
frontera entre Burkina Faso, Níger y Mali.
Históricamente, esta región se llamaba Liptako-Gourma
pero podríamos llamarla “el triángulo
del mal”.
En los últimos años, se ha convertido en
el epicentro de la violencia yihadista.
Sumadle tráfico de drogas, personas y armas,
y ya tenéis el cuadro completo.
Y esto explica noticias como esta:
Francia aumenta la operación Barkhane a 5.100
soldados para centrarse aún más en la zona
de la triple frontera Mali-Burkina Faso-Níger
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero por que Francia,
en concreto, tiene tanto interés en esta
región?
Si seguís VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo,
ya os podéis imaginar la respuesta.
Durante siglos, Francia fue la principal potencia
colonizadora en África.
Hace 60 años, Francia se marchó del continente
pero... seamos honestos: nunca han abandonado
del todo a sus colonias.
Por ejemplo: ya sabéis que Francia es una
de las principales potencias nucleares del
mundo.
No sólo tienen la bomba atómica.
Además, son el segundo país con más centrales
nucleares del mundo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el 70% de la
electricidad en Francia viene de sus centrales
nucleares.
Y os preguntaréis ¿De dónde saca Francia
el uranio para alimentar tantas centrales
nucleares?
Pues muy simple: de países como Gabón o
Chad: ambas ex colonias francesas.
Hasta aquí no hay ningún problema.
Podría ser una relación meramente comercial.
Pero la realidad es que Francia ha estado
poniendo y quitando dictadores para garantizarse
el suministro de uranio.
Para que os hagáis una idea, la influencia
de Francia en África es tan grande que incluso
la moneda que se usa en casi todo el Sahel,
el Franco CFA, está ligada al tesoro francés.
Ya os adelanto que en un futuro esto puede
cambiar, porque los países del África occidental
se están planteando pasarse a una moneda
propia, llamada “eco”.
Pero hasta que esto pase, incluso los sistemas
bancarios de los países que usan el Franco
CFA dependen de París.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando: ¡A ver,
Fonseca!
¡Francia no ha hecho nada que no haga, por
ejemplo, Estados Unidos!
Pues sí, tenéis razón.
Pero como siempre decimos en este canal...
el diablo está en los detalles.
La gran diferencia entre Francia y cualquier
otra potencia colonial es la precisión.
Por ejemplo, Reino Unido colonizó la India
y su presencia llegó a todos los rincones
del país.
Dentro de lo malo, los británicos se encargaron
de construir ferrocarriles, colegios y de
poner seguridad en todas las ciudades.
Francia fue mucho más preciso ¿A qué me
estoy refiriendo?
Pues mirad este mapa.
Lo que estáis viendo es el mapa de vías
de tren que existen en África hoy en día.
La mayor parte se construyeron en tiempos
coloniales.
Como podéis ver, las vías de tren situadas
en el Sahel Occidental tienen en común una
cosa: salen de la costa y llegan al lugar
donde están los recursos naturales.
Es decir, sólo sirven para hacer un viaje
rapidito, recoger los recursos naturales y
volver a la metrópolis.
Eso explica que el Sur del Sahel tenga trenes
y el norte no.
Básicamente, los colonos franceses se preocuparon
por controlar las minas.
El resto lo dejaron completamente desatendido.
Todo esto explica por qué Mauritania, pese
a haber sido colonia francesa, fuera el último
país del mundo en abolir la esclavitud.
Hasta el año 1981, era perfectamente legal
tener esclavos en este país.
Incluso hoy en día siguen existiendo granjas
de mujeres.
Es decir: granjas donde se engorda a las mujeres
para que cumplan con los estándares de belleza
tradicionales.
A todo esto hay que sumarle las sequías y
el cambio climático.
El desierto del Sahara se expande año tras
año.
Según la ONU, la temperatura en esta región
aumenta 1,5 veces más rápido que en el resto
del mundo.
¿Conclusión?
Quitando las minas de uranio y de oro, casi
todo el territorio del sahel está controlado
por tribus.
Los tuareg, por ejemplo, son una de estas
tribus nómadas que lleva años luchando por
tener su propio estado.
Y esta es una más de las muchas etnias que
llevan años peleándose entre ellas.
Pero la pregunta es ¿Por qué esto nos empieza
a preocupar ahora mismo?
¿Por qué Europa está mandando tantos soldados
a esta región?
¿Qué ha cambiado exactamente?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LA GUERRA DE LIBIA
Hay otra cosa en la que Francia es distinta
de cualquier otra potencia: la forma en la
que hacen la guerra.
Mientras Estados Unidos se gasta auténticas
fortunas tratando de reconstruir los países
que ataca, Francia es mucho más pragmática.
Por ejemplo, la guerra de Irak costó a la
Casa Blanca más de 700.000 millones de dólares
¿En qué se fue todo ese dinero?
En tratar de reconstruir el país tras la
caída de Saddam Hussein (Cuestión aparte
es si lo han conseguido o no).
Sin embargo ¿Qué pasó en la guerra de Libia?
Pues justo lo contrario.
La guerra de Libia costó a los franceses
un poco más de 1000 millones de dólares.
Y diréis ¿Cómo es posible que esta guerra
sea tan barata?
Pues muy fácil, porque los franceses llegaron,
derrocaron a Gadafi, aseguraron los yacimientos
de petróleo y se largaron.
“—Oye, Pierre ¡Pero que hemos convertido
esto en un avispero!
¡Que se están matando!
¡Que tenemos hasta el Estado Islámico por
aquí!”
--¡A ver, Jean Marie!
¿Hay terroristas donde está el petróleo?
No ¿verdad?
Pues ale, misión cumplida, vamos para casa.
Y diréis ¿Por qué os hablo ahora de la
guerra de Libia?
¿Recordáis que al principio del vídeo hablamos
del efecto mariposa?
En esta historia, hay muchos puntos que están
conectados.
Gadafi tenía uno de los ejércitos mejor
armados de todo África.
Y adivinad dónde fueron a parar todas esas
armas.
Foco: Armas y hombres provenientes de Libia
fortalecen la rebelión en Malí
Hasta ese momento, Mali podía tener guerrillas...
pero eran guerrillas sin apenas armas.
De repente, todos los conflictos de Mali pasaron
a ser un problema para todo el mundo ¿Os
acordáis de los tuareg?
Los tuaregs son un pueblo bereber del desierto
del Sáhara.
Están divididos entre seis países y uno
de ellos es Mali.
Así que vamos a por otro mapa, atentos:
Como podéis ver, si hablamos de etnias, en
Mali se ve muy bien la división norte-sur.
La capital, Bamako, está en el sur, mientras
que la mitad de la parte norte está habitada
por los tuaregs.
Los tuaregs se habían intentado independizar
varias veces.
Ahora, tenían armas libias para defender
su causa.
Pero esto no es todo, porque además del secesionismo,
la guerra de Mali tenía otro protagonista:
el yihadismo.
Una parte radicalizada de los insurgentes
decidió actuar por libre para imponer la
sharia en toda la región.
Hablamos, por ejemplo, de Ansar Dine: un grupo
islamista tuareg que se creó en marzo de
2012.
Además, teníamos por ahí a otros grupos,
como Al Qaeda del Magreb Islámico, Movimiento
para la Unicidad y la Yihad, los Firmantes
con Sangre… En definitiva, el tipo de gente
que no quieres que tenga armas.
Para el año 2012, la situación ya estaba
escalando a una velocidad endiablada.
En cuestión de meses, ya controlaban el norte
del país ¿Os suena un país que se llame
AZAWAD?
Pues este fue el nombre que los tuareg dieron
a sus territorios conquistados.
El Gobierno de Mali estaba contra las cuerdas
¿Quién podría salvarlos?
¡Sorpresa!
Francia se une a la lucha contra los islamistas
de Mali, dice Hollande
El 11 de enero de 2013, el propio Gobierno
de Mali había pedido ayuda militar a su antigua
metrópoli.
Y el mismo día, los aviones de combate con
banderita francesa ya estaban sobrevolando
el Sahel.
La pregunta es ¿Ha conseguido Francia borrar
el terrorismo yihadista de la zona?
Y, bueno, ¿Por qué debería preocuparles
el yihadismo en sahel?
Preparaos, porque ¡ahora mismo, lo vamos
a ver!
UN ROMPECABEZAS IMPOSIBLE
En el año 2013, el gobierno de Mali pidió
ayuda a Francia.
Desde entonces, el ejército francés sigue
por aquí.
El sentimiento antifrancés en Mali es cada
vez más fuerte.
En Francia existe cada vez más oposición
a esta guerra.
Y en este momento es cuando preguntaréis
¿Por qué Francia sigue aquí?
¿No se supone que Francia no está interesada
en reconstruir los países que ataca?
Punto uno: ¿os acordáis de cuál era históricamente
el principal interés de Francia en el Sahel?
Exacto, los recursos naturales.
Si las fuerzas islamistas llegaran a controlar
los yacimientos estratégicos, Francia se
podría quedar sin el petróleo de Chad, el
oro de Mali o el uranio de Níger.
Vale que ninguno de estos países es un exportador
imprescindible.
Pero hay un problema.
Como os acabo de decir, Níger tiene dos grandes
minas de uranio, una en Arlit y otra en Akouta.
Desde hace décadas, este uranio iba a parar
a las centrales nucleares francesas.
Sin embargo, ahora, muchos tienen miedo de
que este uranio acabe en manos de yihadistas
¿Podrían fabricar bombas atómicas?
Lo cierto es que no.
Fabricar bombas atómicas requiere de una
tecnología casi impensable para un grupo
terrorista.
Ahora bien, podrían fabricar algo parecido:
las llamadas “bombas sucias”.
Es decir, bombas que tienen uranio y que,
al explotar, pueden contaminar lo que está
a su alrededor.
Se ha especulado mucho sobre el riesgo que
podrían plantear estas bombas sucias.
Pero lo cierto es que, ante la duda, es mejor
proteger las minas de uranio.
Eso explica noticias como esta:
Francia está protegiendo la mina de uranio
de Níger
Sin embargo, este no es el auténtico problema.
Y aquí es cuando volvemos al efecto mariposa.
La inestabilidad en un lugar remoto del mundo
puede generar un problema muy gordo en Francia.
Hay una cosa que todavía no os he contado
en este vídeo: el sahel es toda una bomba
demográfica.
Por ejemplo, se estima que para 2050 la población
de Níger se podría cuadriplicar.
Así que tenemos una región cada vez más
pobre, más violente y con cada vez más gente.
Todo esto significa una cosa: una nueva caravana
migrante.
Y, si eres un maliense o un chadiano, ¿a
qué país europeo te gustaría mudarte?
Vamos, un país en el que controles el idioma
y, lo que es más importante, vas a encontrar
a gente de tu comunidad o, si hay suerte,
hasta a tu primo tercero.
Exacto, hablamos de Francia.
Según las cifras de Instituto Nacional de
Estadística francés, más del 46% de los
migrantes que viven en Francia nacieron en
el continente africano.
Y estos datos ni siquiera cubren la migración
irregular.
A esto hay que sumarle la amenaza terrorista
en Francia y entenderéis por qué están
tan preocupados por controlar los flujos migratorios.
Y la pregunta es ¿Qué están haciendo para
evitar esta nueva caravana de refugiados?
Por un lado, tenemos toda una dinastía de
misiones militares.
Primero, en 2013, Francia lanzó la operación
Serval: una intervención en Mali avalada
por el Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU.
3.500 efectivos de Francia.
Un año después, Serval cede paso a la operación
antiterrorista Barján: 5100 soldados franceses
y 405 de otras nacionalidades.
En 2020, la Unión Europea creó un grupo
táctico llamado Takuba.
Todas estas operaciones también han contado
con la ayuda inestimable de Estados Unidos.
Pero, seamos honestos, Francia nunca ha permitido
que la Casa Blanca se meta demasiado.
Desde el principio, todo esto fueron operaciones
lideradas por Francia.
No olvidéis que, para Francia, lo más importante
es mantener la influencia en esta zona.
Y lo último que quieren, a este respecto,
son competidores.
Así que la pregunta es ¿De verdad están
funcionando estas misiones?
La respuesta es...
Francia y Estados Unidos están empeorando
la seguridad en África Occidental
A estas alturas, parece que no va a ser suficiente
con una solución puramente militar.
Otras potencias como Turquía ya han enviado
medicinas y mascarillas a Niger y Chad para
luchar contra el Covid-19.
Gracias a estas ayudas, Turquía está comprando
muchas voluntades.
Y eso explica que Francia esté cambiando
la estrategia.
De las intervenciones militares ultra prágmáticas,
están pasando al palo y la zanahoria: palo
para los yihadistas y zanahoria para los gobiernos
leales.
Por ejemplo, el proyecto de la Gran Muralla
Verde.
Se trata de un proyecto para crear una larguísima
franja de bosques y granjas que evite la desertificación.
Este proyecto se inició en 2007 pero apenas
contaba con dinero: ¿Conclusión?
No funcionó.
Pues bien, desde principios del año 2021,
Francia ha entrado a meter dinero.
Y, la verdad sea dicha, no han reparado en
gastos.
La Gran Muralla Verde recibe más de 14.000
millones de dólares para reverdecer el Sahel.
Francia y el Banco Mundial están en la lista
de donantes.
Pero ahora, turno para vosotros ¿Creéis
que esta nueva estrategia de Francia va a
servir para evitar una nueva caravana migrante?
¿Qué creéis que pasaría si Francia retira
sus tropas de un día para otro?
¿Conocéis algún otro ejemplo de cómo las
antiguas políticas coloniales siguen repercutiendo
en el mundo de hoy?
Podéis dejar vuestras respuestas en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí, en
VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas.
Así que suscribíos a este canal y dadle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.